how are you guys doing before we begin
proceedings I think it will take just a
few minutes of our time to contribute to
what's going on in Bangladesh now what's
going on in Bangladesh is flooding
people need to be alleviated from that
pain and suffering and it will only take
us a couple of minutes and we have a
responsibility as Muslims let's click
the link below and donate now recently
there's been some videos online that
have been going viral actually of me
speaking in one of the sneo streams
which have become uh very popular of
course because the champ is in them uh
and one of those things have been uh one
of those clips have been taken out of
context let's take a look together at
this clip and discuss it our Jesus is so
much more virtuous is the kind of man
any young person would want to follow
they Jesus they may in in their own
religious context want to follow him but
on the in the meantime they're watching
Andrew tape because in a way Andrew
tapate the character of Andrew tapate
has certain that the New Testament Jesus
doesn't have oh
man that's the truth they're going to be
angry on that one it doesn't matter
who's going to be angry doesn't matter I
love
it no I'm saying the new the New
Testament Jesus I'm sorry to
say is is a contradictory figure because
you've got him in when he's got no power
yes he's acting in a very forgiving you
could call it way very Placid way very
docile
way yes but then when he comes back the
biblical narrative when he comes back in
the Book of Revelation what does he do
he kills the prostitute Jezebel this and
that why yeah so the moment you get
power you start it's a killing spree now
so as you can see with this clip um I'm
saying that the New Testament depiction
of Jesus Christ uh is actually a lacking
one one that doesn't give him his rights
as a virtuous character that he is now
as Muslims what do we believe we believe
that Jesus Christ is the Messiah we
believe that Jesus Christ is one of the
greatest prophets to ever live we
believe that Jesus Christ is the son of
Mary the greatest woman who ever lived
ever and Allah mentions that in the
Quran that he chose her over all women
of humanity and there's a whole chapter
in the Quran chapter 19 Surah Mariam
about Mary which
praises and sanctifies the character of
Jesus Christ just like Chapter 3 of the
Quran Alan just like chapter 5 of the
Quran speaks about Jesus in such a
positive manner so not
believing and sanctifying and respecting
in the character of Jesus Christ is a
sin that is worthy to excommunicate
somebody who does it something we can't
expect yeah believe in having said that
some people have tried to say that I am
saying but based on this clip which I'm
sure you educated listeners educated
viewers educated people knew exactly
what I was trying to say in that clip
but I have lied about what I said and
said that I'm saying that Andrew Tate
who I criticized last week is greater
than this Jesus Christ that I've spoken
about this is a
lie and you know I know why people would
want to lie many of the people who have
made videos about me and this issue I
looked at their Channel and found that
they had like a thousand views per video
and then when they spoke about me there
was a spike I understand the incentive I
really do understand the incentive but
lying is against Islam if you are a
Muslim lying and misrepresenting and
slandering and defaming in another
another individual especially a Muslim
it's Haram you I mean there's only so
much you can do in terms of that having
said this what I will say is the New
Testament depiction of Jesus Christ
leaves a lot to be wanted about this
character and as I said it actually
deprecates and diminishes and I would
say even
abases yes abases the character of Jesus
Christ let me give you a few examples
just to let the point be solidified
let's take a look at Matthew chapter
number 15 verse number 24 and look if
you have your own Bible if you're a
Christian watching at home at verses 24
up until 28
what essentially happens in this segment
of the New Testament is that you have a
Canaanite woman who approaches Jesus and
she asks him to help her and her
daughter and what happens is Jesus
Christ um says I was only sent for the
lost sheep of Israel and then she
literally goes on her knees and begs and
pleads Jesus Christ and then he goes
even further and what he says is that
he's it's not right to give the food of
the do the food of the children I.E the
children of Israel and give it to the
dogs I.E the Gentiles the non children
of
Israel
what what is the depiction here if not
of a racist ethno supremacist Jesus is
being depicted in the New Testament as a
racist yes he is he is being depicted as
somebody who's
intolerant of these other people or at
least considers Gentiles to be dogs now
she continues and and tries to persuade
Jesus Christ in the next verse and at
the end of it he heals her uh daughter
and he grants a request after being
corrected by The Woman by the way the
all- knowing god Jesus Christ is meant
to be the all- knowing god is now being
corrected by a
woman yes and changing his mind and then
healing the woman the the other one so
here you have a depiction of Jesus
Christ we consider to be actually
offensive
we consider this depiction to be
offensive I'm just giving you one
example yes this is one example of why
it is that the character of Jesus Christ
in the New Testament is something we
don't
accept we're not saying we're not even
speaking about theological aspects of
him being God or the Son of God or part
of the Trinity which is a later
invention onto the Bible this exact uh
formulation of the Trinity of three
coequal coeternal uh beings this is an
invention a Roman invention okay we're
not even speaking about that issue we're
speaking about how Jesus is being
depicted as a person so number one he's
being depicted as a racist an ethn
supremacist a Jewish supremacist
essentially number
one that's one thing then you
have the pacifist
nature of Jesus Christ and we see this
in in Matthew Chapter 5 5 verse number
verse number 38 39 where the famous
verse of someone gives you the right
cheek give the left someone slaps you
huh gives you a humiliating me being
embellishing slap on the face give them
the left
one what is this on the one hand he's
being very rough and he's being very
Stern and he's being very uncompromising
and he's being racist to this woman yes
and on the other hand here you have him
saying if someone slaps you on the right
cheek give him the left what kind of
sorry to say and I'm not trying to
offend anybody but this is schizophrenia
this is a schizophrenic attitude this is
an inconsistent
contradictory set of propositions about
about an individual here why would I
want to not offend anybody when we
believe Jesus Christ would never be this
contradictory our depiction of Jesus in
the Quran is of a just man of a
respectable blessed man of the
greatest that he is one of the greatest
men top five men who ever
lived and this is the depiction in the
Bible of course it leav
something to be wanted from Jesus Christ
then you have another thing here
look at this John chapter 2:15 where
Jesus Christ literally makes he makes
cords whips out of cords and starts uh
whipping the the cattle and the sheep
and so and then also he overturns the
tables out of anger what is this is this
meant to be the god The Angry
God what is this this is lacking in a
virtue called Temperance when is it ever
acceptable for someone to to do this
kind of a God or a prophet to to act in
this manner on the one hand he's sing
Turn the other cheek the other one he's
making whips and start whipping and and
start turning the tables and so on this
is
honestly tell me if this depiction is a
is a great one of Jesus Christ's virtue
in the new test and then in the Book of
Revelation in chapter number 19 of the
Book of Revelation I think vers 11
onwards he comes back because remember
Jesus in the New Testament yeah when he
has no power is is not actually calling
to Revolution or is's not attacking
anybody except for you know verbally
attacking this Canaanite woman that
we've just seen and being racist towards
her and making whips for the for the
animals and overturning the tables but
when he comes back that passive
aggression becomes not only aggression
but it come becomes dictatorship because
he goes on a killing
spree are you telling me this is uh the
loving and the compassionate and sorry
to say no this is a depiction of Jesus
Christ which we do not accept and I will
say there's no apology to be made if
anything people who accept this version
of Jesus Christ should apologize to us
should apologize to the Muslims for
deprecating and diminishing and abasing
and abasing the character of Jesus
Christ and yes there are people out
there that you know being say for
example a Christian in Africa or a
Christian from the Bible Belt region who
watches the UFC and the WWE and
Hollywood and so on and look at the
protagonists of those films and see a
moral and physical bravery the like of
which even that depiction of Jesus
Christ in the New Testament doesn't have
and there's a reason why people are
attracted is because there's an
intrinsic attraction to the virtues
intrinsic virtues that exist in human
beings and unfortunately the New
Testament uh depiction of Jesus Christ
is lacking in those virtues with Jesus
Christ we would say if you really want
to fall in love with the character of
Jesus Christ and the way that he should
be fall in love with then look at the
look no further than the Quran look no
further than in the Sunnah look no
further than in the the descriptions of
the Prophet Muhammad about this man
where it sivs out and filters out all of
this sorry to say incorrect information
erroneous corrupted information that we
find in these books and of course that's
not to say that the New Testament
doesn't have positive descriptions of
Jesus as well which we accept and
respect and are beautiful like for
example the of the mount or for example
many of his interactions with people and
some the humble and kind nature yes I
can quote many Biblical verses which I
accept and think are a representation of
Jesus Christ but they're also mixed with
these other ones so as Muslims would say
that's why the Quran is M it is a
guardian over the previous scriptures
and that these books are corrupted this
is the view of Islam
that woe to those who write the book
with their own hands and say this is
from Allah to try and retrieve with that
a poultry price or a miserly price woe
to them for what their hands has written
and woe to them for what they have
earned there from meaning that these
books the New Testament the Old
Testament they are corrupted and this is
almost with the consensus of textual
critics of the Christian faith
themselves and I refer you to the books
for example of Bruce mea and others who
talk openly about the corruption of the
New Testament yes Muhammad s wasallam
came after 600 years after Jesus but he
was inspired by God through the angel
Gabriel and the depiction of Jesus
Christ is nothing but a pristine
beautiful excellent depiction and if you
want to be reintroduced to the character
of Jesus Christ then the Quran is the
book for you and believe me you'll fall
in love with him even more and in a more
powerful meaning authent meaningful and
authentic and genuine way than you would
have ever been able to do so looking at
uh Christian theology which is
contradictory of a man God a limited
unlimited being and also a depiction of
a man in this manner so no no there's
nothing to apologize for no no there's
nothing to retract but everything to
double down on and that's what I have to
say